hello everyone
starting in next nine minutes
till then please introduce yourself in
the chat box maybe your educational
background and your research interest
thank you
all right so we will be starting the
webinar in two more minutes and in the
meantime
uh the participants can introduce
themselves in the chat box
so that we can get to know each other
all right so let's start with today's
webinar hello everyone my name is shree
kari krishnama and i would like to
welcome you all for today's webinar on
omixlogic bioinformatics
high school summer training programs and
before we proceed further let us discuss
what these high school training programs
are or all about
so the high school summer programs
provide students great opportunities to
pursue new interests improve existing
skills and brainstorm with like-minded
students
and although bioinformatics and data
science continues to redefine the way
research is carried out it has barely
been incorporated into the high school
education system and to address this
disparity pine biotech has launched the
omixlogic high school summer training
programs specifically
designed to meet the needs and interests
of high school students and the programs
are available in the following areas
biomedical data science using rn python
genomics in virtual lab independent
research project
so before we begin with today's webinar
let me briefly introduce you to the team
behind the programs we are a us-based
bioinformatics company who is working
with multiple academic and commercial
collaborators to develop easy-to-use
analytical tools and make bioinformatics
more accessible
and over the past several years we have
had the privilege of working with a
number of organizations developing a
training program for research oriented
students faculty and democratizing
bioinformatics making this discipline
accessible to thousands of students and
faculties around the world the omics
logic research based training programs
are a result of close collaboration
between pine biotech and numerous
academic institutions that have
participated in content evaluation
curriculum review and project design
now to mention the educational
objectives the omx logic training
follows a project-based learning
approach using research-grade tools to
analyze data from top peer-reviewed
journals the omics logic training has
been completed by students researchers
and faculty in six different
specialization tracks namely oncology
infectious diseases precision medicine
neuroscience data science for biomedical
data and comprehensive training on omics
data analysis
the omex logic training has been
completed by over 24 000 participants
from 187 countries in over 300 workshops
due to this fast growth our team is
working with local and regional
coordinators that are helping refine our
local program logistics and leverage our
online training resources adapting them
to the needs of students and researchers
around the world
so before we proceed further i'd like to
introduce you to the founders and team
members of the company dr alfred tauber
comes from a medical background with an
expertise in oncology immunology and
biochemistry of information and one of
his major projects is the establishment
of the toba bioinformatics research
center which has been at the core of
what we do dr leonard brodsky is the
director of the torah bioinformatics
research center and is an expert in
bioinformatics and biostatistics mr
iriakovsky is the ceo and co-founder and
has a background in bioinformatics data
science project management and
commercial product development
our platform is a result of hard work by
some of the people mentioned here on the
right as well
julia panel who is an expert by
mathematician avi titivitsky leads the
development of the t by info platform dr
mohit mazumdar is an experienced
bioinformatician with multiple
publications in peer review journals and
he has been developing collaborations
with universities as a mentor and
project lead for omix logic training and
research fellowship dr rajvendran
lakshmi narayan is an accomplished
computational biologist with experience
in large scale analysis of
multi-organized data and data science
methods in precision oncology and
structural bioinformatics
all right so now let's highlight some of
the current challenges and limitations
and how we at omixlogic help resolve
these with our training and research
services
so what are some of the challenges that
the field of bioinformatics is currently
facing to begin with this field is
constantly growing and developing new
technology and software to improve
processing time and power the data sets
that are analyzed are usually very large
and take immense amounts of computing
power and memory that many personal
computers do not have also despite being
publicly available data are also usually
complex to access and coding knowledge
is usually required to do so similarly
analysis pipelines and programs require
coding knowledge that many biologists do
not have and in a university setting
students from the opportu students have
the opportunity to learn the background
information of designing and
implementing a bioinformatics project
but they do not receive practical
hands-on experience with the full
workflow due to the limitations
mentioned previously
similarly faculties faces challenges
with being able to cover a diverse range
of topics if they are specialized in a
certain area of bioinformatics or if
they are unfamiliar with bioinformatics
in general for example a professor whose
research focuses on oncogene expression
might not know much about the meta
genomics of seawater
to overcome these challenges the
omixlogic platform was developed this
program aims to standardize organize and
systemize bioinformatics training in
order to make these analysis usable for
any biologist or clinician
some problems are for standardization
materials for these forces are usually
developed in-house taught sporadically
and are rarely updated the organization
because the challenge is to combine
several different topics together the
flow and transitions are needed to be
developed systematization how can you
know that someone is stuck and needs
help or allows someone to run forward
osogen uses standardized modules and
interactive sessions beginning with
mastering terminology and concepts to
implementing these concepts with real
data sets in a project based
now to discuss about the learning
process in order to create a clear path
of the skill development omx logic
employs the bloom's taxonomy levels of
learning this approach starts with the
basics that is students recall facts and
terminology and are able to repeat and
memorize the material with this base the
learning builds to conceptual knowledge
being able to understand concepts and
apply information to new situations the
student will then be able to analyze
data by drawing connections and evaluate
when to use certain methods this leads
them to the highest level of learning
the ability to design and create
original work
so how do omixologic resources help
advance bioinformatics teaching
omix logic is a portal for practical and
theoretical learning of bioinformatics
it is composed of courses designed to
take you through the theoretical
knowledge omixlogic takes a combination
of training modules data analysis tools
curated project data sets and
interactive sessions with mentors to
give a student a clear path of the
bloom's taxonomy permit and no matter
what the user's initial experience with
bioinformatics is omixlogic is a useful
tool for gaining a baseline knowledge of
the theory behind bioinformatics
analysis of large data sets and
introduction to basic coding languages
like r and python or even beginning a
data analysis project
the users will be given directions to
access the t bioinfo platform
for bioinformatics processing and
analysis of transatomic data the
platform includes demo pipelines as well
as data management and analysis cloud
infrastructure to run bioinformatics
pipelines and different stages of
analysis are performed in different
sections
in this multiomics platform
this program comes with an access to the
omixlogic courses which includes courses
on bioinformatics precision medicine
multi-omics including genomics
transatomics metagenomics and even
epigenomics data science that includes
bioinformatics using rn python hours at
all
and examples of projects of different
fields which you could
learn from and replicate for your
research work are being displayed on the
screen
so first of all let's begin by signing
up on the portal
so here i'd like to pause and sparsh has
shared the link to the learn portal so
please visit the portal and from here i
will show you how to sign up on the
portal so once you have visited the page
please leave a yes so that i know i can
proceed further and i'll show you how to
login
all right so
i'm going to sign up on the portal so
first you need to click on the login
when you click on the login if you do
not have a former account you have to
create an account and here you just have
to enter your name email id and password
or you also have the option to log in
using your google account facebook
account apple account github account and
even twitter account
so once you have signed up on the portal
please leave a yes so that i know i can
proceed further
i'm curious are there any participants
who have already signed up on the portal
if so you do not have to sign up on the
portal again you can directly log into
your account and from there i'll take
you on how to access the various
resources
and if you have any queries regarding
signing up on the portal you can leave
that in the chat box and our team will
be happy to help
all right clement has said that uh
there's already access to the account
okay
all right so i'm going to log into my
accounts i already have an account i'm
going to click on login
and when you sign in
the first thing that shows up is this uh
display so from here what i want you to
do is click on the tab that says welcome
back with your email id
once you click on that it will take you
to your account and here you need to
have an updated profile picture
your name in full name
with proper capitalization and you need
to link your social media handles and
also a brief bio about yourself that is
it can include your educational
background and your research interests
so if you are to navigate further if
you're interested to check out any
courses that are
of your interest so let's say genomics
just type in the keywords and you will
find um the associated courses we also
have several example projects that you
can get access to once you enroll for
the program so for that click on the tag
here that says project
so this will show up all the projects
that we currently have
all right
so next we'll be hearing from mr alia
brotsky about
what are the various benefits and
outcomes uh and who's who are going to
be your mentors uh during the program
so now i'd like to request krishna to
play the recording
in my part of the presentation i will
briefly talk about
what the
level topics are that we're going to
cover
and discuss how you might benefit from
participating in the program what might
be the possible outcomes i'll introduce
you to some of the mentors that will be
helping you along the way and show you
some examples of students that have
completed this program and what they
have done with the information that they
received
so as you all know
we live in the age of data and
specifically in biomedical research or
in biology there's a growing
source of data and one data in
particular called next generation
sequencing data is becoming
kind of the foundation of a lot of the
different research topics that are being
done in biomedical research and
agriculture and biotechnology etc so my
background is actually not in
bioinformatics but i came into
bioinformatics by working with pine
biotech and the different collaborators
that include multiple research
universities
biomedical
research projects and consortia and i
had the privilege of
training
and
working alongside experts and students
in many different institutions here in
the us
so as a result of that
i've seen how uh it's really
unpredictable to know
who becomes uh you know an expert and
who leaves and who kind of chooses
bioinformatics is their topic and for a
lot of people what i've discovered is
it's not clear what bioinformatics
actually is and how is it applied in a
variety of domains
so my first part of today's session is
to explain why bioinformatics and what
is bioinformatics and how data in
biomedical research is actually used to
advance the application of insights from
such analyses to
precision medicine
biotechnology agriculture etc so
first of all kind of a historical
background since the
1950s when the dna was first discovered
the structure of dna was clarified we've
seen how such information has led to new
discoveries starting from the sequencing
annotation and discovery of the human
genome and the genes that are
responsible for different proteins to
technologies that make such data easy to
produce
and eventually to use
in large-scale initiatives like genomics
england
the broad institute
different
medical centers that actually use
insights from genomic data to categorize
diagnose and treat patients
now the basis of that is that
when we understand the code and we
understand what the code actually
produces so how nucleotide sequences
form amino acid sequences that are the
basis of proteins
we can start looking at variation of
that dna code that is responsible for
some specific phenotype or in this case
in this example you can see sickle cell
anemia actually a change in a particular
amino acid leads to a change in
a cell structure right and so
that kind of an ability to
detect changes
has led to
a number of very clear applications so
for example drug metabolism how
different individuals metabolize
different drugs whether they will
respond or not respond to treatment
identification of mutations in cancer
cells identifying genetic predisposition
or disorders like sickle cell anemia
inherited mutations
rare genetic diseases
as well as drug resistance and different
pathogens and these examples are all in
the context of biomedical research and
medical application in the context of
precision or personalized medicine
because what happens in the medical
context is today clinicians have to deal
with such information to actually make
a better
description or characterization of
disease for a patient and and one of the
things that we now are starting to see
is that you have these panels of
specific genes specific
proteins
and
you can now identify mutations that are
responsible for
very dangerous diseases like cancer now
as researchers continue to study these
they actually understand that
some specific genes in the genome are
responsible for the most uh serious
effects so for example tumor suppressor
genes encoding genes dna repair genes
they accumulate mutations that are most
dangerous one example is the tp-53
mutation that
is a gene p53 protein
tumor protein p53 is encoded in that
gene and what that mutation does is it
can actually alter the structure of that
protein and make it not functional and
if it's not functional it's a tumor
suppressor gene so then it does not
suppress the tumor growth because it
does not respond to the damage in the
dna and leads to accumulation of
mutations
so finding such mutations can be
critical for accurate and precise and
effective cancer cancer treatment
in cystic fibrosis
you have
mutations that are responsible for the
functioning of
the cftr channel
which is responsible for
getting the right kind of
chloride ions out of the cells and if
it's not functioning it leads to
accumulation of mucus and can be very
dangerous so
knowing how to find these mutations and
understand their function is clearly
important and not only is this important
for individual mutations this is also
important for large scale rearrangements
like copy number variation uh repeats
that expand a particular region and and
one way to find those variations is to
perform genome-wide analyses that take
thousands of samples for clear
phenotypes and start understanding what
are the statistically significant
patterns that occur in a large
proportion of the population
such studies have led to discoveries
including tuberculosis drug resistance
which is a disease that is affecting
millions of individuals around the world
if someone can monitor the participants
and make sure that no one
think if you could keep them unmuted
thank you
so drug resistance
not only to individual drugs but
multiple drugs is starting to become a
huge problem
and we see the same in the
world of viral pathogens so for example
the ebola outbreak and how that leads to
tracking of transmission and vaccine
design but also the current pandemic of
covert 19 we hear about variance of
concern all the time so all of these
project examples all of these
you know examples in precision medicine
in population health
genetic predisposition to disease
all of these have been transformed by
the availability of these different
types of sequencing techniques so in the
program what we will try to do is
introduce you to how such data is
generated what is the process of
acquiring actual digital data from a
biological sample and then in that data
set how do we work with
different algorithms computational
algorithms to understand mutations that
are pathogenic neutral
that are maybe not very bad or bad
and how do we determine the effect of
these mutations in the genome so how do
we actually
categorize them how do we understand
their impact on the phenotype and what
are some examples where you can find uh
the you know clear association between
individual mutations and the phenotype
and so that is really what
bioinformatics is all about so
bioinformatics is about taking
information or data
taking methods of computational analysis
statistical methods machine learning
analytical methods and applying them to
biological data sets applying them to
data sets where we have biological
samples conditions clinical conditions
etc and so the program is going to
tie together these three different
domains
in a way that you can quickly see the
application of bioinformatics to a
number of different domains so the
omixlogic
programs are going to help you not only
understand how these things work but
also practice and apply them and so in
the context of this program these
resources that were already mentioned by
israeli are going to be critical to
getting you from maybe not knowing a lot
about bioinformatics to getting an
understanding of what bioinformatics is
and how it applies to eventually
starting to use it maybe in your own
project or a group
and so here
we're going to try to cover a variety of
different types of
examples or projects that are case
studies that you can use
to really understand and develop a sense
of you personally discovering something
on your own using some of these tools
now i imagine that most of you here have
understanding of what bioinformatics is
maybe not a lot of experience and that
is really who the program is for
now i want to specifically highlight
two
project
or two resources
on the onyx logic portal
where you can get started so even if
you're here for the first time
now that you have registered
you can go to the omixlogic portal and
find two specific courses one is called
introduction to bioinformatics
and another one is called bytes and
molecules so sparse or somebody maybe
can
uh
yeah someone can maybe post the links
uh so if you have um
an account and you've signed up again
the sign up is free those are two
introductory courses that will get you
started they will get you into this
context that will explain at a high
level the different applications
introduce you to our community the way
that things are organized and you will
really get a good sense of why
bioinformatics is it for me and what can
i do with it
okay thank you tash so introduction to
bioinformatics is that first course and
the second course that i wanted to
mention is called bytes and molecules
so again if you search here bytes and
molecules it is course two and this
course is
different from the introduction to
bioinformatics because it is a little
bit more detailed and actually
introduces a lot of the concepts that
are going to be useful for what we do in
this program and that includes
terminology or what are these terms like
snips
you know variants gene expression
profiles etc it will give you a sense of
the relationship between
code
and structure and how things work in the
cell
and then it will introduce you to
specific types of data that could be
that could be acquired from next
generation sequencing so genomics
transcriptomics and metagenomics and
talk a little bit about maybe things
that you haven't thought of how
bioinformatics is actually used to study
precision medicine or astronaut health
in space
now also a big component of
bioinformatics as i mentioned is the
application of data analysis techniques
and tools to large data sets and coding
is a critical component so as you've
seen one of the critical elements is to
understand how and why and then have the
practical skills and so the second
option that was mentioned in the
beginning so the first one was genomics
in the virtual lab the second one was
coding or biomedical data analysis in r
and python so in this course you will
already get an introduction to
coding in r which is a popular
method of analyzing different types of
biological data where you will have
access to different examples of just
getting to know what coding is why do we
need coding and how to read
use
to load the data things like that so
that's going to be very useful because
one of the practical examples here is
the ability to actually run code and
practice fixing the code that is given
to you without having to uh you know
take too much time
of
yours
to actually learn everything from
scratch so we're not going to learn
things like hello world we're going to
jump into how to load data and this data
is going to be biological data or the
type of data that you are expected to
use in the domain of bioinformatics and
once we get into this you will see that
you will start to appreciate syntax you
will know how to load and produce uh
simple plots that are informative you
will
interpret these plots and then as it
becomes more and more complex so here
you will find assignments
those will introduce you to more and
more complex methods of analysis
including analysis of complex data
analysis using complex methods like
machine learning and deep learning and
also ability to integrate multiple
sources of information to actually
answer real research questions
so along the way as you go through this
course work you will realize that a lot
of this course work is sourced from
experts in the field
and experts in the field are people that
have a long history
of
maybe doing research or using such
skills in the domain of biotechnology
and pharma
and getting to know these people you
will realize that they all have a rich
history and a path of how they got to
where they are today so to briefly
introduce some of these people
i want to
highlight a couple examples
and those examples are going to
demonstrate kind of the quality of the
people that you will be
exposed
[Music]
all right so before we proceed further
if you have any queries please put them
in the chat box
uh
and our mentor is here so we can answer
any queries that you have
so in the meantime uh
as you heard from mr aliapotsky the
various benefits and outcomes of the
program we realize how challenging it
must be for chil students especially
high school students to get
opportunities in research or research
opportunities so that is why we have
been constantly working with experts in
industry and academic to develop high
school training programs that are
designed to meet the needs and interest
of students so for that
we have prepared a short survey that
would help us if you will provide with
your feedback so i'll share my screen
so uh this is the survey so i'll quickly
take you through this uh there are very
few uh questions that are being uh such
as your name your last name your email
id your phone number or your country
your city and then it starts with
whether you're a parent or you're a
child you can fill out the name of your
high school and the eligibility for the
program is from 8th grade to 12th grade
and then you can mention your current
level of your education and select the
program that you are interested to
participate in then you can also uh
select the ideal length of the program
that would better suit uh the learning
pro uh the learning progress and you can
also select the time of the day that
would work best with the schedule and
finally what are the expected outcomes
after completing the program
so uh
the link to the form has been shared by
sparsh in the chat box so it would be
great if you could take a little moment
to fill out the survey that will help us
uh in improving our programs
so next we'll be hearing from dr
raghavendran so i would like to if
if the participants are not having any
queries we will be moving on to the next
part of the webinar all right so if you
have any queries uh as the webinar
progresses please put them in the chat
box and for the next part of the webinar
i would like to uh passed on to krishna
to play the video recording by dr
uh it looks like she has been
disconnected
okay you're there could you please share
the screen krishna
uh hello krishna uh am i audible
i apologize for the delay uh right she
is back
so now we will be hearing from dr raghav
indian about how the omics logic
programs help bridge the gap between
peace and advancements energy and
learning
it's very
all right so meanwhile krishna is back
maybe we can uh have a chat with the
participants and listen to their
research and trust and what type of
training are they looking forward to
so clement i saw that you are very much
interested in the programs and enjoying
pretty early yeah so clement could you
please introduce yourself and tell us uh
about your research and trust
and what makes you join the uh webinar
today
okay um thank you for
giving me the opportunity well um
i'll be following the ohmic logic
training programs uh
i i joined this particular webinar to
get more insight
otherwise my primary interest is on the
fellowship
uh so that's where my primary interest
is but just to get more insight into
the omic logic that's why i joined this
uh
webinar i've joined previous webinar
it's not my first time here thank you
all right thank you clement it was nice
to know about you
and i can see that krishna has joined so
hi krishna uh do you have a better
network can you share your street now
yes yes i'm sharing the same screen
sorry for the inconvenience yeah
all right
india from institute of bioinformatics
and applied biotechnology bengaluru and
javalal nehru university
this is where um it was instrumental in
helping me develop a deeper
understanding
in the
in the area of bioinformatics research
applications to variety of different
data sets so for the past eight months i
am part of this wonderful company which
gives me opportunity to share my
learning to inspiring students like you
so over the course of my career or over
the course of my tenure i have been
involved in projects from variety of
different backgrounds that includes
protein structural biology that includes
agriculture
that includes multiomics data analysis
like genomics transcriptomics
epigenomics data etc
and these are mixed data are quite from
a variety of different
sources like
model systems
like from patient resources unlike from
agriculture resources and etc so this
variety of projects and this uh
wide spectrum has been immensely helpful
for me to tending to students with a
wide range of interest and in
in pursuing research training with us
so to give you an idea of uh
of my research
interest and background give let me
share one of the interesting projects
that i i was involved in
during my career
so this is a project on precision
oncology and to introduce you to
precision oncology uh first let me tell
that
most of you would have already known
oncology is a study of cancer biology
and we know that cancer is the leading
cause of disease states worldwide for
such a dreadful disease and for disease
with such an impact um
systematic carrier treatments have
relied on drugs which are
chemotherapeutic drugs and these drugs
are marginally more toxic to the cancer
cells than normal states i mean such an
approach is not very ideal and it gives
us or results in a huge problem because
on an average only 25 percentage of the
cancer patients respond positively to
these cancer drugs but in comparison
over 80 percentage of the patients
respond to popular painkillers like
aspirin that you get over the count
so one of the prominent solution to this
problem is precision ontology so
precision ontological therapy is is a is
a strategy
where the treatment is actually designed
by targeting the molecular
characteristics of the patient's tumor
so hence the treatment that is given to
the patients are personalized to the
to those patients who are likely to
respond to specific therapies and
therapeutic approaches
so the way that we have approached or
the way that i have addressed this
precision oncological
problem issue
is to implement data-driven approaches
to include multi-omics data for
understanding and for predicting
patients response to a variety of cancer
treatments
so how do i do this
the tumor cells that that form cancer in
patients are
collected in during biopsy and are then
subjected to next generation sequencing
techniques and the information about
gene expression the information about a
mutation and the information about
epigenetic variation that characterizes
the gene expression were extracted and
they were recorded
this data or these omits data
molecularly characterizes the tumor so
these are different from from
different types of tumor and different
subtypes of human
and then these tumor samples are then
grafted or then administered
several cancer drugs and their response
is studied by
measuring their bond
so this data records the tumors of
reaction and response to different
treatments some for some treatments the
tumor will diminish in volume and for
some of the treatments it will not
respond positively so these responses
and the molecular
characterization data characterize data
where then integrated and various
machine learning algorithms and deep
learning algorithms were applied to
understand how they are related so from
this relationship we were able to
predict which patient or which cancer
from which patients
were able to positively or will be able
to respond positively to the treatment
that is that they are subjected to or
from the list of multiple treatments so
this is how we approach uh understanding
cancer biology from
multi-org data different approaches
so projects like these and various other
projects and example projects
methodologies and resources are compiled
and explained
expertly in the learn omics logic
platform so while you are enrolled in
specific programs that addresses your
interest you are also welcome to explore
various such resources under example
projects and expand your horizons in the
field of bioinformatics data analysis
so as i have already mentioned my main
involvement in this
is with the students
who are enrolled with research
fellowship program
this research fellowship program is
designed to address key challenges that
every student will face
while
subjecting or while opting for a
bioinformatics research so if you are
interested in extending your enrollment
for research fellowship program after
the completion of your specific program
then you would also
be able to leverage all the resources
that are developed to overcome these key
challenges like
time involved in learning and testing
out a lot of different strategies and
time and access to bioinformatics
expertise and access to
big data infrastructure
so
who will benefit from a research
fellowship program like this and who
what will the students like you take
away
from these research fellowship program
so for students who are new to
bioinformatics and who does not have an
early exposure to bioinformatics this
gives you an excellent opportunity to
develop an exposure to the methods to
the logic behind these methods and
analysis and to practice your knowledge
that we have gained throughout this
program uh into a research project that
interests you or research project that
will help you in your care
and for students who have some exposure
to bioinformatics and who already know a
little bit of bioinformatics you will
gain expert feedback and project
evaluation
that will take your project from a
superficial investigation
to
superficial investigation
to a full-fledged research project that
fulfills many prominent criteria for
being a successful publication so you
will also be interacting with mentors
like me and dr mohit and elia and
understand where and how to find complex
data assets that is going to help you
design a very specific bioinformatics
project
and this project as i have already
mentioned
can be developed or can be uh
designed with an aim to obtain a
research complication by the end of your
trainer
so with that i will conclude my
presentation and i look forward to
interact with all of you during the
program and see most of you for the
research fellowship program
all right thank you so much so if the
participants have any queries so far
please put them in the chat box i'll
wait for couple of seconds before
proceeding with the next part of the
webinar
so if the participants have any queries
if you don't have any queries you can
leave a no
and
we'll proceed with the webinar
all right so let's move on to the next
part of the webinar
that is i would like to introduce you to
a
former high school student who was who
joined our program
his name was andre muadano sosa and he's
a high school student from mexico
and from joining the omislogic summer
research fellowship program as a
complete beginner in bioinformatics and
data science to winning awards at
international science competition andre
offers a great example of how a high
school student can make a difference in
the scientific community with the right
amount of quality training he completed
his project on evaluating the role of
microglia cells in the pathogenesis and
progression of alzheimer's disease under
the guidance of doctor hatred core
further he went on to present his
project at the regeneron international
science and engineering fair 2022 which
is the world's largest global science
competition for high school students and
where he won fourth place in the
biomedical and health science category
and for his initiative and
groundbreaking work to push forward the
study in brain degenerative diseases
andre also won the potemkin price for
students
and in a while we will be listening to
andre present his research findings
before that let me give you a brief
overview of his project
that is the pro his project aims to
evaluate the role of microbial cells in
the pathogenesis and progression of
alzheimer's disease and for this purpose
he made use of a transatomic data based
on a study that was conducted on
transatomic profiling of microbial cells
in aging patients and from performing
rna-seq pipeline to quantifying gene
expression levels to gene-set enrichment
analysis there are several processes
that he performs to gain insights from
the transatomic data and do not worry if
all these terms sound too technical the
full video contains a lot more
information that the participants can go
through in their own pace so for now let
us see what is findings bear that won
him the several prizes at international
competitions so again i would like to
pass on the stage to krishna she'll be
playing the video
so the results from itunes enrichment
analysis reinforce the notion of neural
inflammation and microglial immune
activation
as central mechanisms in the
pathogenesis and progression of
alzheimer's disease
and based on the fact that the main
difference
between wildlife and adbps one mice
is that the latter over produce amyloid
beta
i mean they show an increased
aggregation of the amyloid beta peptide
uh we can infer that this aggregation
these are signal plagues
likely constitute the cause of
microglial uh
immune activation
and based on this we can sort of imagine
a positive feedback loop
in which amyloid beta aggregation leads
to immune activation and general
inflammation which then in turn
exacerbate the aggregation of amino acid
beta and the development of nfds of
neurofibrillary uh times
oh sorry
uh yes uh so since there was an increase
in the biological processes involving
neutrophils both across aging and
between pathological and physiological
conditions
i would like to talk a little bit about
neutrophils
so neutrophils are the most abundant
type of white blood cell in circulation
in our bodies
they modulate immune processes and have
also been shown to play a rather
important role in pathological
inflammation
and you know tropicals are a type of
white blood cell known as granulocyte
and these granulocytes contain a type of
secretory vesicles known as specific
granules
yeah and so when neutrophils are
degranulated which was one of the
biological processes that we could
observe
uh yeah here neutrophil degranulation
um
basically what happens
is that a
the
the neutrophils are secrete these
granules these are vesicles which mostly
contain molecules that are toxic to the
cells
so they secrete cytotoxic molecules
and additionally the activation of
neutrophils
can lead to other important immune
mechanisms such as phagocytosis
the production of reactive oxygen
species
and the secretion of pro-inflammatory
cytokines
um okay um yeah so amyloid aggregation
may induce the expression and secretion
of these uh pro-inflammatory cytokines
in alzheimer's disease
i would like to know what are the
molecular mechanisms that regulate the
expression of these
cytokines
all right thank you so much krishna so
we have a query in the chat box from
mohinit uh can we have the pre-recorded
video spash could you please answer that
yeah
so uh definitely after this webinar
we'll be rolling out insights mail so
maybe by tomorrow morning you'll receive
the meals regarding the
um
regarding this full session so you'll
definitely receive one
all right so if the further if the
participants don't have any further
questions uh let's move on to the next
part of the webinar so now i'd like to
invite uh sparsh third to talk about the
registration process and the various
scholarship available for the
participants over to you
so uh thank you sri gauri and krishna
so hi everyone i am
and i am working as business development
associate at fine biotech
so now uh
we i'll be telling you about the program
session the interactive session schedule
about the different resources one would
have access when they enroll in the
program
and also about uh the pricing and the
scholarship one could agree
so
let me share my screen
uh so srikuri could you please confirm
if my screen is visible
yes now just
okay
so
first of all the name of the program is
high school summer training program
but it doesn't mean that it is only
meant for high schoolers anyone who is
beginner in bioinformatics and
want to upgrade their skill in
bioinformatics and data science
field they can
apply for this program
and they can further move on with this
program also
so there are three uh different programs
which we are providing right now with
under this high school
training program so one is the
biomedical data science using r and
python
another is genomics in the virtual lab
and the third one is the bioinformatics
in bioinformatics research fellowship
program
so i'll talk about each and every
program one by one
starting from the biomedical data
science using r and python
so
this is the program page so shrikari
maybe you can share the
link in the chat box
yeah i think so she has shared perfect
so
yeah moving further
in this program page you will find about
the program overview what actually the
program is all about
what you will be learning in
terms of like uh python and our
programming the different statistical
analysis visualization annotation etc
so here you will
get to know about a program overview
what the program is all about when you
scroll down you can find a calendar
where there are
like when the uh where there are some
specific dates highlighted so these are
the dates where when the session will be
live or maybe asynchronously uh like the
mails will be rolled out to you
asynchronous so that you can complete
your
sessions your assignments your lessons
your coursework at your own pace
according to your visibility and time
so uh
here
now these are the sessions
on which you'll be working on
so we have divided different sessions
starting we'll be guiding you will be
training you from basics and till the
advance so the first session is about
the basics of programming for r and
python
each session uh here you will find the
topics where we will be covering in each
session also the date when uh of the
session
and when you will be part of the program
you can find the recorded session the
session recorded recording also here in
the program page itself
with other online associated resources
so moving on to next then you will learn
about introduction to r and python where
you will be covering about
why to use r and python you will be
covering what are the basic data types
in r and python this data structures in
r that is vectors matrices data frames
list etc
then you will learn are in respect to uh
working with sequences
so uh for example introduction to dna in
genomics reading fasta files in their
length etc so this is the session
schedule which will be following for
biomedical data science using our and
python programming language
now if you scroll down you will find the
fellow like you will find the program
length there are there are three
different program length
and uh the resources
also
if you scroll up you will find a
drop down menu
where you will like where you can see
the pricing for the program in your
location
according to your location for example
if you are from nigeria
then we have specifically uh
naira is mentioned the currency naira is
mentioned if you are from india then you
will get to see the pricing in inr if
you are from um
us you will get to see the pricing in
usd so right now uh i'll click on usd so
that
okay
so there are three different in yours
for this
particular program
one is 45 days tenure another is 60 days
10 year and then it's 90 days 10 years
so each tenure is having different
pricing as you can see for 45 days it's
one dollar 150 usd then for 60 days it's
taller 300 usd and for 90 days it's
taller for 50 usd so this pricing is
specific to location
if you uh check out for a nigerian
community or african community the
pricing is different it's according to
their currency if you check for
india the pricing is according to their
currency so it will keep on changing
according to the currency upon the
location which you opt for
now talking about the sources
so some of the common resources uh for
all these tenure are one
you will have access to the omics logic
learn portal as srivari has explained
you earlier in the session
then you have access to rt bio info
server so it's basically an ai based
cloud pipeline where there are different
two
kits which perform different
functionality
so you will have access to that then you
will have access to our coding sessions
you will have access to our all the
online associated resources which
include uh example research projects
uh then
number of courses a number of lessons
then case studies etc
then you will have access to our online
mentor support so by online mentor
support i mean
that uh
we'll be creating a specific skype group
for specific program and all the
participant of that particular program
will be added into that skype group so
for example other than the live sessions
or live q a sessions if while going
through the lessons or going through the
training in between you uh find a query
or something and you want to get it
resolved on immediate basis you can ping
your query in the skype group and the
mentor will be there to assist and help
you out
now moving on to the uh
uh next access you will have access to
online technical support as well
and when the program will complete you
will get a certification completion
certification
so this is the these are the common
resources which you will get for all
these tenure now what's the difference
between the three is for 45 days you'll
be focused we'll be focusing on like for
just just for training but
okay for 60 days you have an opportunity
to have one-on-one mentor guidance in 45
days there is only online mentor support
but in 60 days you have an opportunity
to get clarified your doubts as
one-on-one mentor guidance other than
that you have an opportunity to draft a
research proposal and present it to our
mentor for evaluation purpose
then the outcome for this uh
60 days tenure will be like uh you can
create
a poster out of your uh
training what you whatever you have
learned and you can present it in
our research symposium or different
hackathons or international conferences
then talking about the 90 days tenure
other than one-on-one mentor sessions
you have an access you have an
opportunity to work on a complete
research project
and also you can further publish that
research uh
project into a publication research
publication so this was about the
resources the difference between the
three ten years and the pricing
now moving on to the
second
that is
yeah
so
the second uh
program is bioinformatics and data
science research fellowship so when you
scroll down again i have opted for naira
i'll
and this time i'll opt for india
so that everyone should get to know how
it looks like again you will get to know
about the program overview
how we'll be like
for how we'll be taking you through the
research fellowship program what all
skills you will be gaining
uh what all uh conceptual skills you'll
be gaining which you can eventually use
in your like
real life applications etc so now here
you can see the proper framework which
you'll be following
while your research fellowship program
so introduction evaluation then practice
uh then comprehension and analysis and
investigation and in the end you will be
writing whatever you have learned in
your
training annual analysis part into a
proper scientific
report form
so when you scroll down again
you will find
three different tenures
three different pricing and the
resources are same as i just discussed
for the
biomedical data science
uh using r and python program
now uh moving on to
the third program that is genomics in
the virtual lab
just a moment
yeah uh just a moment
i don't know what happened
okay perfect
uh so talking about high school uh
high school program for genomics in the
virtual lab
so when you again scroll down you will
find the program overview so this
particular program
here the mentor of the program is dr
sona vasudevan she's a professor in
georgetown university medical center
and she is the one who will be like
teaching you and guiding you and
training you throughout the
program
okay so moving on to further so this is
again the session schedule where you
will get to know about the topics we'll
be covering
about the outcomes about the associated
online lessons and tutorials uh for each
session and when each session will be
out uh so
the first session as you can see is
induction to bioinformatics where we'll
be telling you about the different omics
technologies in the 21st century the
role of big data in biomedicine the
different tools and resources then we'll
be moving further with introduction to
protein structure and function sequence
alignment and phylogeny and so on so uh
krishna has all shri body has already
shared the link of all the three
programs in the chat box you can go
further with the
links and you can explore
on your own
now moving further again we have three
different tenures and there are three
different pricing this time i have opted
for um like
the naira and uh so that everyone can
see because we have participant from
african community as well in the session
and the resources is same for this
particular program as well
so
this is all about the session schedule
about the resources and the pricing
so now if anyone is having any questions
related to registration or pricing or
scholarship
so please let me know in the chat box
thank you
uh yes thank you so much uh uh you can
also share the
uh email id and phone number so that the
participants if they have any queries
you can contact us directly yeah yeah
definitely so if any participant who is
having any query related to uh
like registration or resources or
scholarship they can email me at
marketing at the rate omixlogic.com
or
or they can connect like they can call
me on the official number that is
for a specifically for indian contacts
but this number is active on whatsapp
also so whosoever uh like across the
world they can connect me via whatsapp
if it's like applicable in the in their
region whatsapp app is applicable in
their region
they can connect with me via whatsapp so
i don't think so shri body we have any
question related to resources and other
stuffs
so i think so it's good to go now
i have a query that is for the
independent high school project which
program to do it is by samir
uh
for independent yeah so it's
bioinformatics research fellowship
program sami
for independent research project you
need to opt for by
bioinformatics research fellowship
program
i'm sharing the link to that program
once again in the chat
yeah that would be great
thank you
so does any other participants have any
other queries
if not uh we'll be ending the webinar
and thank you dr raghuvan uh
for um
are present till end of the webinar so
thank you so much for being here
pleasure suppose thank you
so i think sushi body we are good to go
thank you everyone for joining thank you
thank you everyone
thank you